you keep going back to rights which is
interesting to me because I I don't
think of politics primarily through a
lens of Rights but you do you keep going
back to rights fundamental rights to do
whatever whatever I want with my body in
these circumstances or whatever so okay
if we're talking about rights
are all rights equal or All rights on
this you know my right to have this pink
fruity drink here is that the same as
your right to I don't know drive a car
or something no I don't believe they're
all equal no okay all right so then
there are gradations of Rights some are
more important than others is there one
most important right that you would call
it a fundamental right the fundamental
right the right to your body and the
right to decide what happens to your
body there's no right that that precedes
it
I mean it depends
what what rights do you think perceive
that please well it seemed to me that
the the right to your body
the right to do certain things to your
body must necessarily be preceded by the
right to life without which you do not
have your body or the ability to do
anything at all
well and as I've described Your Right to
Life does not get to supersede or
overwrite some override someone else's
right to bodily autonomy but I thought
we just admitted that it did because I
thought we just agree oh you didn't
agree with that okay because it seems to
me if we're going to have any rights at
all the right to drink my fruity drink
the right to have a lovely conversation
in this kind of black room here any of
these other rights that all of those
rights depend upon the right to life
which is not just one right among many
but is it is the fundamental right and
so therefore if if rights are to have
any meaning at all
the right to life must supersede all of
the other ones and I disagree I think
that you have I think you have a right
to life but your right to life does not
override someone's right to bodily
autonomy why is that true because you as
I've asked you quite a few times now you
cannot describe to me one instance
except motherhood where it is acceptable
for you motherhood's unique but I'm just
saying what you are saying that the
right to do whatever you want with your
body supersedes the right to life it's
more fundamental than the right to life
and I explain to you why I think that
the Right to Life Is Fundamental and uh
more important than all those other
rights and I gave you maybe you don't
like my argument or something but I
think I at least spelled it out in a way
that's fairly clear and logical so what
is your argument as to why the right to
control your own body is uh more
fundamental than the right to life
because I think that if you allow the
government to decide that someone else's
right to life life can override your
right to bodily autonomy that is opening
the door for a lot of terrifying things
to happen this is why you have to
volunteer to be an organ donor this is
why you have to volunteer to be a Blood
Donor things like that if if we allowed
the government to say that someone
else's right to life can supersede your
right to your body that is a pretty
terrifying amount of power to give to
the government we're speaking about I
mean you're talking about organ
donations but we're speaking about this
unique case right because no we're
talking about the use of your body right
but but for instance Bronte uh I have
kidneys
I don't need I don't need both of my
kidneys I maybe I do to filter all these
terrible things I put into my body but I
don't really need both of them I could
give them to someone else but it would
be wrong if the government came in and
said Michael we're taking your kidney
now because Bronte needs it I might give
it to you voluntarily but I certainly
wouldn't want someone coming in gunpoint
taking my kidney away that would be
wrong even if even if you were in Dire
Straits I I wouldn't I I still might
give it to you but I don't want someone
taking it from me and I don't think that
I have an obligation to give you my
kidney right because my kidney is for
filtering my blood that's what it's for
right uh in the same way a woman's womb
is for nurturing a child that is the T
loss that is the the purpose of the womb
it serves no other purpose so I don't
think that these the analogy that you're
making here is apt I think once again it
gets back to the unique status of
motherhood so the the same thing can be
said for your liver right your liver no
one wants my liver well but your liver
the purpose of your liver is to detoxify
your blood it can it can process alcohol
it can process all kinds of toxins but
if I don't ingest those toxins then my
liver doesn't have to do that job if I
don't choose to Harbor a fetus my uterus
doesn't have to Harbor that fetus just
because your body can do something
doesn't mean that you should be
compelled to for it if you choose not to
have a drink
then your liver is not going to process
alcohol there's no way the alcohol got
in there but if you decide after I don't
know you know you had a crazy weekend
you went out here to Nashville met a
nice guy you would never do this but I'm
saying you know women of ill repute
would go out and you know they meet a
guy he's not so nice
anyway the next morning she finds out
she's pregnant really four weeks later I
thought it'd be very bad but mothers
know you know and anyway she finds out
she's pregnant she says oh darn I don't
want to be pregnant and you know that
that baby has no right to be in my womb
she has engaged in behavior that that
would introduce the baby into her womb
in the way that uh if you put the drink
down you will not be introducing alcohol
to your liver so should we then deny
Health Care to alcoholics because they
partook in behaviors that cause them to
have liver failure should we deny
smokers access to medical care because
they partook in you know in behaviors
that damage their lungs no no no but you
believe we shouldn't kill them though I
don't think we should kill them you know
or steal their livers or anything like
that I don't think we should go in and
kill the baby just because but you are
saying that you get to judge someone
based off of their behaviors and because
of those behaviors and because of those
behaviors you believe that they should
be denied Access to Health Care in order
to address the effects of those
behaviors and not if it's a drinker not
if it's a smoker but if it's a woman and
then sure now we get to remove the right
to her body and the effects of her
behavior no well and I I guess we're
again missing the point I don't think a
mother ever has the right to kill her
child in any circumstances so I I I'm
not uh suggesting that we single mothers
out here or that be very judgmental or
anything like that or deny anybody
health care I just don't think that
killing a baby is ever health care I
think that's a euphemism and that's
where you kind of admitted at the top no
that's what we talk about the
distinction between babies and fetuses
see and that's that's where you're wrong
though because when we we've talked
about maternal mortality rates we've
talked about the number one cause of
death for pregnant people maternal
legality is still very low by the way
right do you know the amount of people
who have do you know the difference
between maternal mortality and maternal
morbidity
uh no it enlighten me so morbidity is
essentially unforeseen or serious health
effects of a medical condition so
maternal morbidity is when someone
experiences severe complications of
pregnancy and labor and I know that you
think that seven to eight hundred women
dying annually from pregnancy is too low
for you to care but you should bring the
number down right later but abortion it
but babies to pretend to resolve that so
60 000 people every year have serious
maternal morbidity which means there's
certain codes that they use and like
Insurance codes that they use to
determine whether or not you experienced
a severe side effect and some of those
codes are being having an ICU admission
or needing multiple blood transfusions
things like that and 60 000 women every
year are admitted into the ICU or need
both transfusions what have you that's
qualified definition of a of a severe
morbidity there's I think we're talking
about
are we talking about certain things that
are less it's severe that's what would
be something so it depends because it
can be sepsis Hemorrhage
um I think pulmonary embolism there's
there's multi there's multitudes of
different complications that we're not
talking about something like tearing or
something no that's minor and that's not
included in Sixty thousand so that's my
point is 60 000 women every year
experience severe morbidity and that's
not including the women who just develop
things like diabetes or have a perineal
tear oh well this is that's actually a
very important point that you bring up
of some of these problems that go along
with pregnancy because something that
the abortion Advocates mention that
often is not addressed by the pro-life
movement not not that I think it needs
to be but it's interesting nonetheless
is that the United States is not the
best when it comes to maternal mortality
we're not the worst but we're not the
best and and there are lots of problems
with it but the reason for that of
course is not because of Any uh
conspiracy among the doctors or you know
misogyny or anything like that I don't
think I think it probably has more to do
with America's disproportionate rates of
obesity and heart disease and diabetes
you look especially it's not as though
complications of pregnancy are the same
across all demographics it's largely
concentrated in black women and the
reason for that it would seem to would
seem to me is that black women are much
more likely to be obese and have heart
problems and have diabetes and all those
things that are that that do factor into
pregnancy problems but that's not a
again I don't think any of that is a
good argument to kill a bunch of babies
every single year but that seems like a
health issue that should be addressed
elsewhere right